why you should learn how to train an
automl video classification model you
may have seen my short on training in
image classification model and this is
basically the same but for video automl
video is part of vertex Ai and helps you
train machine learning models to
classify and track objects within videos
this includes annotating videos with
custom labels doing video streaming
analysis and Shot Change detection the
model then analyzes the video data and
returns a list of categorized shots and
segments check out this tutorial to try
it out for yourself it uses sports
videos on cloud storage to train a
classification model which predicts a
single label for a given video shot and
frame for example is this person doing
cartwheels or riding a horse see the pin
comment for a link to the tutorial now
you know